- [Voiceover] So we're told
that the first four terms
of a geometric sequence are given.
So they give us the first four terms.
And they say what is the
fifth term in the sequence.
And like always pause the video
and see if you can come
up with the fifth term.
Well what we have to remind ourselves
is for a geometric sequence
each successive term
is the previous term
multiplied by some number.
And that number we call the common ratio.
So let's think about it.
To go from negative 1/32,
that's the first term
to 1/8, what do we have to multiply by?
What do we have to multiply by?
Let's see.
We're going to multiply,
it's going to be multiplied by a negative
since we went from a
negative to a positive.
So we're going to multiply by negative
and there's going to be a one over
let's see to go from a 32 to an eight,
actually it's not going to be a one over.
It's going to be, this is
four times as large as that.
It's going to be negative four.
Negative 1/32 times negative
four is positive 1/8.
Just to make that clear.
Negative 1/32 times negative four
that's the same thing
as times negative four
over one.
It's going to be positive.
Negative times a negative is a positive.
Positive four over 32.
Which is equal to 1/8.
Now let's see if that holds up.
So to go from 1/8 to negative 1/2
we once again would
multiply by negative four.
Negative four times 1/8 is negative 4/8,
which is negative 1/2
and so then we multiply
by negative four again.
So, let me make it clear.
We're multiplying by
negative four each time.
You multiply by negative four again,
you get to positive two.
Because negative four over negative two,
you can do it that way, is positive two.
And so to get the fifth
term in the sequence,
we would multiply by negative four again.
And so two times negative
four is negative eight.
Negative four is the common ratio
for this geometric sequence.
But just to answer the question,
What is the fifth term?
It is going to be negative eight.